cette semaine à paroles autochtone
quelles sont les origines de la banique
oui mais bon à part à l'automne quand
même si c'est melissa maulin depuis
alors pour répondre à la question
d'elisabeth quelles sont les origines de
la banique j'ai pas besoin d'aller très
loin dans l'histoire de la banique elle
remonte à cinq cents ans
c'est quand il ya eu les premiers
contacts avec les européens qui ont
amené la farine de blé et les
programmations qui le faisaient aussi
une forme de galettes de pain mais avec
les ressources végétales qui avait
autour de certains allaient utiliser le
cambium c'est à dire la partie qui se
trouve entre les corses et l'arbre de
certains arbres chez que le boulou et
pouvaient utiliser ou l'érable certains
utilisent et même des bulbes comme le
kama dans l'ouest les morts qui
utilisait le maïs faisaient une farine
de maïs
mais quand l'arrivée du la farine de blé
s'est faite là on a découvert une
recette de pain végétal mais qui était
délicieuse très sucré aussi d'ailleurs
c'est très dur en amérique du nord de
trouver des sources de glucides pourtant
donné une énergie rapide on avait
beaucoup de protéines et de graisses
mais pas autant de glucides donc la
banique a vraiment été adoptée
rapidement et en plus les écossais qui
ont emmené une manière de faire la
banique le faisait sur un credo qui est
un peu comme une plaque plate
un peu comme on faisait les galettes
nous sur des roches plates qui était
chauffé la différence pour qu'on a pris
la banique et non le pain à là où le vin
ou à l'éleveur
c'est que ils se conservent beaucoup
plus longtemps il voit même avons
tendance à durcir avant de moisir donc
on pouvait la faire cuire dans la sauce
et elle est redevenu un peu plus molle
et on aller pour la manger donc c'est un
peintre voyageur
quand les chasseurs cueilleurs c'est sûr
que tu va favoriser ce genre de plat
mais ici la recette s'est modifié quand
même destin en ouest et du nord au sud
parce qu'il existe partout en amérique
du nord
donc certains vont la faire cuire sur le
fond dedans le faut nous chez les inouk
on va même la faire cuire dans le sable
où on va tâcher sable mettre la patte
laisser le sable sur le dessus et
laisser le pain est cuit
juste gratté un peu il y aura pas de
sable dans le passé avec délicieux
situer plus à l'ouest ils ont tendance à
faire frire et ou à la faire cuire dans
le four
il ya des ingrédients qui vont se
rajouter certains moments des pépites de
chocolat s'appelle vont mettre des
petits fruits
ça change vraiment d'une nation à
l'autre mais c'est vrai que c'était un
produit qui s'est fait adopter
culturellement et non pas approprié
parce qu'il ya eu un échange de bons
procédés et que le pain et système
partout dans le nom de toute façon alors
je vous invite à découvrir la recette de
banik local proche de chez vous a fait
même l'essayer et je vous invite aussi à
partager cette vidéo s'il vous a plu et
à pouvoir discuter un peu plus
longuement sur la banique et sur ses
origines écossaises et autochtone je
souhaite une belle semaine à l'espace
autochtone